[Music]
coffee or tea coffee baby why well I
like coffee - I mean I like tea as well
but coffee just it's just very soothing
to my soul I don't know why coffee or
tea tea because it made me go into labor
I think being from Seattle it's kind of
like in your blood you know tea because
I don't like coffee because it's fruity
tea it's sweeter
well I think coffee in the morning right
and like tea at night and afternoon tea
like all day unless I like have finals
with tea coffee the tea is just like too
gentle when I'm getting caffeinated I
want to be like crackdown coffee
America
Coffee because tea is for British and
you guys threw it in the lake the ocean
that was probably a good idea
because you know whatever about the
green tea coffee hurts my tummy and tea
is more delicious
there's more varieties of teeth you guys
argue much about it yes he loves coffee
great coffee
it tastes better and you know I don't
drink coffee for the medicinal effects
or you know to get my energy going I
just like the taste of coffee tea
because it's part of my culture I grew
up with tea and I love the tea and I
love I love the different kinds of tea
that you can drink and you can drink hot
tea or cold tea just like it all the
time and and for the variety you can
drink coffee the same way
[Music]
Coffee power because it's addicting and
my body feels like it needs it I say tea
cold tea I don't drink coffee because I
don't think it works so I'm super a DD I
don't think it does anything it doesn't
wake me up it tastes like crap unless I
put a bunch of stuff in it and T is just
really good cold and my mom loves tea Oh
coffee
that's an easy one smell I love smelling
it oh it's being made and it's got more
caffeine
how's your screen cheap
[Music]
because followers is real coffee
and when I drink of you for me it's like
I'm in the heaven
coffee tea just disgusting
this to me I think I probably choose tea
because like growing up at the Asian
household we always like drinking like
we never really went to coffee like
every time we would have Chinese New
Year's I like celebrate anything it
always be tea like tea is just like
unity you know like more of a battle a
stirring I'm gonna go with tea actually
all right have you ever seen someone
with their enamel so corroded by coffee
that it's just you're looking like
you're seeing a just a sea of brown as
opposed to some kind of you know teeth
are normally attractive sorry I just
that's my two cents but uh with tea or
you're really uh you're cutting down on
the corrosion factor the discoloration
factor and essentially you're getting
less caffeine because caffeine small
dose is good for you high doses I mean
you can see where I'm going with this
but uh that's just how I feel
tea definitely tea I just personally
know that T is when I'm relaxed and
enjoying myself and copies when I've got
to do other things to please others that
gets me going but tea is tea is
something you can do to enjoy yourself
and relax coffee definitely
I mean teas okay but it's kind of bland
coffee
I feel like it's more flexible I mean
you can add milk to it
half-and-half sugar no sugar espresso
coffee probably in the u.s. you grew up
more around a coffee culture but it's
just great when you travel tiny
different specialty brews and especially
drinks you don't get the same thing from
tea tea I really love to yes I think
it's like you feel more awake we drink
like black tea then when you drink
coffee I think and it's yeah it tastes
better and
I don't know I just like tea coffee can
give you headaches coffee coffee
prolongs your life
[Music]
weren't you that like them - where do
you have evidence yes it was two days
ago in the news
[Music]
you